Hey and so are we
hi guys this is welcome welcome to what
specifically this is a show that answers
your biggest questions about every
single episode of Game of Thrones I'm
Phillip Melina and I'm Erik vos and
episode 2 actually had no death yeah
shocking there was also no dragons I
think maybe because we had a direwolf
yeah I'm we're not that both the same
person and we had a few seconds of White
Walkers specifically White Walkers the
most White Walkers we've ever seen in
one place yeah and not White's which I
do have a theory about that we get into
later in general though I thought it was
a really nice touching the great hour of
television yeah it was just kind of
beautiful a lot of like emotional
moments I feel kind of drained you know
I could use a horn of that Giants milk
that tormund was going way into who know
I think it's a little too late for you
irreversible because we wanna remind you
guys that all of our Game of Thrones
coverage is available on this Westeros
weekly podcast feed we're still gonna do
our great episode breakdowns again
that's a reminder to all of you that
scream at us every time you guys better
not be replacing the breakdowns yeah
there don't we we're everything's
additive if you see that in the comments
let them know hey no they're still doing
the breakdown and those actually come
out later in the week but you get all of
our season 8 content and audio form
earlier in the week earlier than video
versions just get that on the Westeros
weekly podcast I've done iTunes or
wherever you get your podcast also just
real quick we started a new podcast feed
for our MCU content so if you're a fan
of all our Marvel stuff it's called
inside marble and it's covering right
now obviously a little movie called
Avengers and gain oh yeah that thing
yeah but let's get into your guys's
great questions that you have I'm gonna
answer them we're also gonna hit up our
weekly Power Rankings that you guys vote
on every week but let's just start with
maybe the big question yeah let's do it
what is this you cut it in wet wet haha
the green egg all right let's see what's
inside
whoa a little message is in it okay here
we go @ DK in 71 500 asks is hiding in a
crypt a good idea when fighting someone
who reads the dead okay so this personal
in Constanta where what we're thinking
here a lot of people actually are
bringing this up I destroyed that egg
yeah so this place is where there are
hundreds of years worth of dead people
to hang out when the army of dead comes
into town and you know so the dead isn't
just gonna be coming from outside the
gates it literally could be coming from
inside the castle oh the calls forming
from a phone that doesn't exist yeah
I've heard that so so here's the issue I
think that this is actually by design I
don't think they're they're like
slipping up like wait let's put the
characters in there I think that we're
seeing some machinations at work of
setting up something much greater than
than we've anticipated over and over
again in the episode characters keep
saying the safest place is going to be
in The Cribs
that sounds way too good it's like check
off script right like he can't keep
setting up this script and then not
delivers some got a horrible thing to
happen down there yeah I mean to be
clear check out script is an actual
place where the man is buried so it's
not a horse cremated all right well so
the crypts are as we understand it we
follow what's been said this episode
there are going to be filled with the
women and the children but also I
remember as Ned umber just kind of
creepy reminded us last week the night
king and the show's not afraid to kill a
kid or a bunch of kids I turned them all
into screeching whites yeah
also Gilly tells that that little girl
with the scar on her face that they're
gonna need protectors down there and um
which could be something I need to pay
off right there could be some
foreshadowing yeah it's interesting that
you bring up that little girl because a
lot of people are saying that there's
scars on her faces sir Davos gave her a
peculiar look obviously she's reminding
him of Shireen Baratheon whom he had
that strong friendship with she taught
him how to read
how to put letters together to form
words and why it's weird that there's a
G in the word night but it's it's this
emotional moment he knows that she was
burned alive and that's there was a
powerful thing that divided him in lady
Melisandre so if these kids do get
turning the whites down the Crips are we
gonna see like a moment where he can
repeat history and burn this sweet
little badass oh my god well in that the
mother face she's making in the graphic
we chose she doesn't look so sweet yeah
but that is crazy
one of our Stardust question askers and
we'll get to those later pointed out
that in this moment you can kind of hear
a serene song oh yeah that music yeah
yeah thanks for that observation but
okay so here even though we're all on
the same page now like yeah maybe it's
not gonna go so well I think that this
is setting up for something even bigger
than just oh maybe the dead get
reanimated in there and they they
slaughter these people so I think some
of the most interesting and important
action of the next episode actually will
take place in the crypts rather than in
the battlefields mmm we do have that
moment that we saw in the initial
trailer of Aria running in the castle
seemingly you know I know you theorized
about what she could be running from
right but it's important to recognize
that's happening inside the castle there
was also in next week's preview and
we'll look at it again at the end of the
episode
there's characters that are very scared
inside of the castle so I think if we
kind of look at what happened here we
put a lot of very important characters
in the crypts right we have Tyrion is is
gonna be there they made a big point of
that Sam is gonna be in there we know
from the clips Barris is gonna be in
there also sense is gonna be in there
these are two important of characters to
put down there and then not be relevant
to what's gonna happen in next week's
episode also I'm gonna throw in there
real quick obviously there's a lot of
dead Starks in there we said that a
second ago specifically though one throw
out one we don't know so much about
Ned's headless body right but we know
that Rickon is down there they made a
point of telling us it's down to it also
made a point that that body has not been
burned right so we could have Ghost
Recon yeah we know Ned Stark's bones are
down there Littlefinger told Rob told
Jon this back last season I personally
saw the ER but its body is like a
skeleton at this point we don't know how
much tissue has to be every kind of like
what's happened
the children of the forest you know with
the former Kings that could be skeletons
yeah the skeletons could come alive yeah
yeah but I don't think we could
recognize Ned Stark's come right ahead
yeah but or maybe we can the acting is
that good but okay so here's my point
all of these characters down there and
in Tyrion is down there
we had a big conversation between Tyrion
and brand that we did not see what
happened wait yeah yeah yeah
so Terry now knows information and they
make a point about how he has the best
mind in Westeros he's the ultimate
strategist right so if he's in there he
has his extra information and all the
characters seem to be like getting
pushed back in there I feel like this is
gonna play out like the Battle of Helm's
Deep
oh yeah the Rings you you and I were
talking about the the directing of the
episode it implies that it definitely
did yeah Miguel suppose a botched Nick
who directed a hard home and the Battle
of bastards
he had the whole crew when they closely
studied the Battle of Helm's Deep in the
two towers to figure out how they could
conceive and direct the different
movements to tell different types of
stories and different areas that focus
throughout a big sprawling battle in
order to humanize it from different
points of view and specifically we're
talk about how that battle includes many
of the people of Rohan in the Crips or
in the in the caverns and the tunnels
deep in the walls of the of the castle
and how that battle the orcs keep
pushing in further and further right ask
the battlements and the different layers
of the castle it's kind of like these
these moments that happen in the best
drama and ironically the ones coming to
mind in this moment is actually a Toy
Story 3 where they're headed toward
toward the flames right oh yeah
melted but my point is more these things
where that's really weird things become
so dire they really feel like I guess
they're all gonna die then and we've
seen Miguel's pops next show us that in
a couple of different ways right with
with hardhome but also with battle the
bastards specifically the way that that
it was at the pinch maneuver basically
that was being used and also it was
referencing Ron and a bunch of other
great warriors always yeah yeah
he showed so many different ways to make
it feel like there's no way out of this
battle and of course not last time was
the Knights of the Vale
last minute I think that this is just
one more way to show us this is this is
absolutely going to go as bad as it can
yes they're gonna lose on every front
it's
get all the way push down into these
crypts and the last surviving characters
might be literally just the people in
who made it to the crypts and then maybe
there's some sort of special way out
maybe it's very very menacing actually
the children before saying to and the
hold the door moment right it was
alright getting pushed back further and
further I think that's what's gonna
happen next week but we're gonna find
out so soon if I'm completely wrong yeah
it it seems like the idea I mean brand
told Jamie earlier let who knows if
there's an afterwards and it's
suggesting this idea there's at least as
possibility that this could end in fold
defeat despite how confident these
characters are that there's a way out
this could end in disaster for them in
retreat of survivors falling back to
some other location for a more intimate
battle happening later in these final
four episodes and we saw that teaser
that aftermath teaser that you know I go
more into this in a breakdown that I'm
working on of like the kind of imagery
is this something that is predicting
something we might actually see or
something that brand has already saw
maybe clue Tyrion in on and that's what
the conversation was that we didn't see
right so I'm just predicting one it's
gonna be with this episode where you're
you you realize you haven't taken a
breath in like I'm sure there's
something right like we're gonna be
holding our breath a lot - this one's a
swing because that could be a mess
because
sbatch Nick doesn't do this normally but
I think it could be directed more like a
horror movie - yeah it's a combination
of helms deep but also there's you know
something in the dark and there's kind
of like a zombie a Night of the Living
Dead for sure who I'm so excited yes I'm
very very excited a Raven puppet did you
squeeze out that a graven okay well I
was a green dragon egg boy okay well and
question LJ Santos asks us what's the
significance of the song that Podrick
sang in this episode that's an
interesting question a very interesting
moment that had a lot of like backstory
and connection books yeah the the the
iPod is blasting a gorgeous song Jenny's
song right Jenny of old stones also
that's actually a we hear the version of
the song at the end which by Florence
Machine which also would have been
amazing
for the credit description yeah I kind
of had a moment where they were like is
anyone here a singer and then just ed
Sheeran just walked back in like
actually and I never blink anymore yeah
it's it is from the book so partially
right right yeah this it's from the
books the character of Jenny of old
stones is is alluded to and introduced
we hear this song while we look at a lot
of our favorite characters in a montage
foreshadowing that some of them will
probably die and some of them will be
left behind to remember those that have
died and this episode Sam told us that
remembering the memory of humanity the
history of humanity is what makes us
human that is our existence but talked
about in the books
Jenny song in the books it's about Jenny
of old stones who had a love affair with
Prince Duncan Targaryen from the duncan
egg series and he abdicated the throne
in order to marry her so Duncan died of
the tragedy of summerhall is a big
explosion that was a result of his
father King Aegon v trying to bring
dragons back to Westeros and Jenny
brought a woods which to court with her
and the witch predicted that the prince
that the prince that was promised or
azor Ahai those prophecies are now one
of the same it sounds like that this
prince or princess would come from the
bloodline of Eros and rey ella Targaryen
which is why they married because they
wanted to keep that in their bloodline
and those are Daenerys ha's ancestors
and John's ancestors which hints that
one of them will probably be azor Ahai
and so we're talking this song has a
direct relation to John and Daenerys is
lineage it's not just like a random
thing it ties into their ancestry yeah
it could also be the song that so the
Rhaegar Targaryen was always known as a
famous singer it could be this song that
maybe he's saying to Lyanna Stark oh
yeah they're like win win her heart
right yeah also I want to mention that
that song is also about what is
happening for us as the audience if you
go back and you listen to the lyrics
it's essentially this moment of us
having like not wanting to say goodbye
to these characters this episode was
very much a love song to the characters
of just like don't we love these people
so much and everyone's given their
purest character moments and it's kind
of just like like I don't know if you
had that moment last
while watching but especially while that
song is playing and we have you know
brands smiled why not and we're sitting
there kind of like man I never want this
to end right it we're talking about Lord
of the Rings with heldens deep but it
seemed like there was another Lord of
the Rings reference here and I'll dig
more into this in the breakdown because
there's actually some really interesting
parallels but Pippin one of the Hobbit
sings this and Return of the King the
third movie during the the failed attack
on Minos ptarth and and we see like a
montage of different elements of the war
charging into battle and you see it on
human level you see it on the king´s
level and his kind of arrogance is he's
I mean food while he's sending his son
and other characters off to die
essentially on the front lines in the
same way that this beautiful voice is
ringing out to kind of put us in this
headspace right as we're about to fight
in this horrible battle it seemed like
the directors of this episode David
Nutter was kind of borrowing it yeah
there's nothing like a high-pitched man
squealing now alright but we got to move
on
to answer some more of your questions
about this episode first we got to take
a quick break to thank two of our
sponsors that help us bring Westeros
weekly to you every week first off the
cyber crime can happen to anyone
there are crooks out there looking to
steal your passwords or credit card
details stealing data from unsuspecting
people on public Wi-Fi is one of the
simplest ways for hackers to make money
other than getting a job to protect
myself from cyber criminals I've been
using expressvpn for a lot of my
navigating around the internet it
secures your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address it has a really easy
to use app that runs in the background
of your computer your phone or your
tablet and so I just turn it on it's one
click and then it's makes it so you can
safely surf on public Wi-Fi whenever you
know I do a lot of my writing at coffee
shops and I use it there yeah it's just
less than seven bucks a month and you
can get the same expressvpn protection
that I have that I use constantly it is
by the way especially PM is the number
one VPN service rated by TechRadar it
comes with a 30 day money back guarantee
because they're so proud of what they do
protect you your online activity today
and find out how you could get three
months free of expressvpn
at expressvpn dot-com slash rockstars
that's expr ESS VPN dot-com slash
rockstars again that's three months free
we
a one-year package so visit expressvpn
comm slash rockstars need to learn a
bunch more great yeah expressive is
great it see I've definitely had my yeah
it's never fun so this is a way that you
can just stay secure and then no one's
gonna peeping and no third parties no
we're dads are gonna be like making
assumptions about what kind of person
you are and sending you other weird
stuff yeah yeah and also thank you too
away travel for sponsoring this episode
away travel is a design company that
makes the world's coolest suitcases
they're made of a lightweight
polycarbonate material that comes in
four sizes and in nine colors so that
you can match your suitcase to your
house sigil if you'd like the coolest
feature is that each bag comes with a
built-in charger for electronic devices
very cool and a single charge of the
away carry-on will charge your iPhone
five times let's look at this thing I
love my away carry-on
it looks cool it has lots of pockets and
sections for all of my smaller items I
like trinkets items yeah your stop very
often at the airport but this thing's
amazing so get your own cool away
luggage at away travel calm and use
promo code rockstars for $20 off your
order
again that's away travel calm and use
the promo code rockstars for $20 off
cool I love next question next question
comes from at Briggs asking where was
the night king and what is his plan so
this is an interesting question because
lot of people are asking this and on its
face a lot of people are just like well
we saw at the end of the episode there's
a giant line of white walkers and you
know the one there he is thinking
somewhere there no he's actually not we
don't see him now of course he could be
holding back he could be allowing his
infantry and his Calvary to maybe swoop
in first do the damage hey Lincoln on
Vissarion hill so he set his alarm for
like 10:30 a.m. gotta sleep in I gotta
stay sharp you see our tips but we also
learn
the night Kings motivation this episode
and now these things are starting to
kind of develop into maybe there's a
second plan that we don't know about
here yes yeah for sure so brand this
week said of the night King wants an
endless night to erase this world and
erasing basically what bran is the
living history as a three-eyed raven and
by erasing the memory in the history of
humanity you erase the existence of them
all of them yourself and this might
debunked the theory that of other things
that the night king might want like
revenge on the children of the forest
unless you consider the three-eyed raven
an emblem of the children in the forest
and maybe getting revenge is still in
play but it sounds like he just kind of
wants destruction he wants endless night
and he doesn't sound like he wants to
rule or win the game of Thrones he just
wants it all to go away bran is a
roadblock to that plan to that Inlet and
game
some might say brain is a three-eyed
Raven memory of the world night King
wants to erase that memory the North
remembers yeah it's a plot of cocoa yes
it's exactly cocoa yeah but erase the
ofrenda of the previous generation which
is bran
yeah okay so we know that the good guys
planned we're getting by the way to
where the night King might be we're just
setting the stage here so we know that
the good guys plan is to kill the night
king you know by drawing him into a
brand's conference room yes hours
meetings in front of the weirwood tree
jenny preserve this tree for me please
all right the good guys plan is to kill
the night king there and hopefully that
in turn kills all the white walkers and
the whites too which i think is a decent
plan right you hack the mainframe upload
a virus take down all the drone
Independence Day yeah White Walkers give
it a cold yeah basically so they're
gonna do that by leaving Brandon the
godswood by himself and with beyond who
is the only person on the show
apparently does not have a Valyrian
steel sword yeah but and it means a lot
yes the best fighter I know but it's
fine because brand is only the hope for
all humanity
yeah but okay so if he's gonna meet the
night King they're surrounded by the
weirwood trees which these are the trees
that kind of give brand his power and
get the ability of sight basically
theoretically then we have this idea
that the night king would be caught off
guard right
socialize plan for him but why would he
not be expecting that right why would he
not understand that they have the
three-eyed Raven they probably know that
I like killing me could take everyone
down they were like well he'd be smart
enough not to you know come out from
from behind and just get attacked but if
he's that smart then maybe he's so smart
that he's not even there yeah it's
interesting there is a theory that we
have talked about before that the night
King might not even go to Winterfell he
might skip over this and this has been
online for a bit I'm sure some of you
may even thought this a couple years ago
that the night King might instead go to
King's Landing and instead convert the
entire Lannister army and that golden
company into an undead army that he
could now bring back up north and attack
Winterfell with a bigger force and kind
of close in on them from two different
fronts right a two-front war the plan
the allies used in world war two against
Germany right make them fight a war on
two fronts
yeah and that's unwinnable yeah the very
cold side up at Stalingrad warmer side
in the French trenches yeah it's exactly
coke oh yeah so you know what works
about that it would address if there's a
if he comes in on the back of this area
and or ice Aryan then wouldn't that
finally pay off the image of King's
Landing being burned down and clearly
like some sort of huge destruction has
happened there of course it could still
come from natural battle but I know it
feels like there it always felt like a
dragon was to blame for that and we just
had never really considered well the
night king of the Dragon he can get
there real fast yeah you know back in
season six there was that one like
future vision montage where we saw like
rapid-fire visions from bran when he was
touching the weirwood tree and one of
them showed the shadow of a dragon
looming over the roofs of King's Landing
and you know some people thought that
was paid off when drogon and and
Daenerys arrived for that big council
meeting at the end but we didn't see
that in particular and the fact that
that still hasn't been officially paid
off made people think that maybe that is
what we're gonna remind her when we did
see King's Landing burned down there was
snow right so it's not it you know if
you just think it was just an error or
she daenerys it doesn't bring winter
with her yes that's true but
someone else does someone else does all
right so uh moving on to our next
question some of you guys actually been
submitting questions to us by tagging
new rock stars on the app Stardust
that's how we take our video questions
so the people by the way who submit
questions that way and tag us follow us
on Stardust you follow Game of Thrones
and you tag us every week you get
entered to win a free trip to Los
Angeles watch The Game of Thrones finale
Wickham hang out with us yeah so
definitely great reason to submit your
questions via star dust everyone that
you're about to see on the starters app
they do their reactions on there but
they submit their questions every week
each one of these people is now up for a
chance to to get flown out to watch the
game of Thrones finale with us at a
screening party excited about alright
let's listen to our first one okay I
just got done watching season 8 episode
2 game of Thrones a question I have is
who makes this out alive because we do
have three more episodes that for this
my guess is John interesting yeah I'm
not a bad guess right a TJ Reese 12:59
Erik who do you think makes it out alive
um I think a good chance of someone to
survive our people like bran or at least
Samwell Tarly because they're so focused
on what's next carrying on the torch of
the history of Westeros so even though
that they might be or Samwell might be
down in the crypts and some stuff might
go down there I think he's gonna make it
out okay and I think characters like
Tyrion still have more to do I don't
think this is his final episode yet
because he hasn't yet completed this
Redemption arc he's made too many
mistakes and seems like the show is
setting them up to come back and redeem
himself so unless he does in some way
that saves the Battle of Winterfell and
he's the hero of that battle I think
there's still more story for him to tell
beyond this episode I might be eatin
crow which is going down on a crow
you made it that gross joke about men at
the wall okay so I think you can't
underestimate though what you what you
just said about or it could be you know
that he goes down saving them I think
that we're definitely gonna see moments
like that and this it's like how Hodor
went out right i this idea that may be
the last act someone does is the
completion of the redemption art and
when you start thinking about that
well now it's like Oh everyone could die
right like yeah and I think they were
trying to foreshadow the deaths of
everyone yeah I except for a few
characters so right Jamie could die in
the last act of that finally redeems him
Sir Brienne now could certainly die
she's finally gotten the acknowledgment
that she's always wanted
Sir John you're like all these
characters want this this Redemption I
feel like they almost gonna be like
trying to dive on the grenade I mean no
I'm the one that he said he redeemed
this way since we're all yeah but yeah
because also I mean if it was Joss
Whedon running this show some of them
are just gonna die abruptly you're just
gonna die and there's not gonna be a lot
of meaning to it we're just gonna be
real sad too but in terms of who makes
it through I think one of the few
characters that did not have death
foreshadowed upon her is Sansa yeah she
has clearly the ability to motivate an
internal conflict on the heroes side
with this idea of the north isn't going
about to to Daenerys Targaryen don't
know if they they might take on
Targaryen though so that's something to
consider but as of right now they just
started a new sense of tension and they
didn't really give her any finality in
this episode so I think she's gonna make
it through the next episode
real quick someone who I think they did
foreshadow potential death for is Arya
yes and what I'm specifically gonna
acknowledge is you know what she didn't
say to death not today she said we were
probably gonna die tomorrow yeah that's
interesting finally is kind of
acknowledging it might it might be time
to die she also didn't say I enjoyed
that that was worth it it's that she
looked over at the camera in this
haunting thousand-yard stare after sex
with Gendry I mean what does that mean
what sex is like pornography how do you
experience them oh do we have another
question yeah to salvage us from this
topic yes next artists question hi there
I'm Victor from Africa Zimbabwe I just
want to know do you think
brian is prophesying Jamie's death okay
so speaking of characters that are
potentially foreshadowed to die bran has
faded reunion with with Jamie or the I
guess three-eyed Raven does so the
question that Victor here is asking is
did bran actually kind of slip up and
hint that Jamie might die do you know
what moment I think yeah it's in the
godswood and he says who knows if there
is and afterwards yeah which a real
sneaky interpretation of that is for you
for you yeah or for all of us but why
would he say it specifically to Jamie it
it seems like this is a second one where
branch just like using his haunting tree
boy stare to rattle the Kingslayer after
earlier saying the things you do for
love I think he doesn't maybe it's part
of the three-eyed Ravens vision in order
for success to happen that the
three-eyed Raven not feels so confident
and we saw how later or that the
Kingslayer or not feel so confident and
later we saw Jamie talked to Brian and
say I'm not the fighter I used to be I
want to serve under your command maybe
that's part of his strategy is to shake
his confidence a little bit so that he
reunites not just this important
relationship with Brienne but the two
swords they carry are part of the same
original sword ice and maybe in order
for destiny to move forward these two
swords have to be brought back together
so that Ned Stark's wisdom and his
legacy and its bravery can help lead
them to victory so you think you'll
wield two swords in his one hand yeah at
some point though put swords together
they'll fuse together and they'll be
wanting why don't they just make his
other hand one of the swords oh you talk
like ash from evil - like yeah this has
a stabby like heavies or from Walking
Dead how did they not think of this we
better write them yeah send a raven the
fools yeah so yeah I think to answer his
question it could be foreshadowed but I
like your idea that bran is actually a
master manipulator of his conch of his
confidence and that makes me think we
need a video and we'll do this after the
season is done looking back at
everything brand has said and seen if he
was doing Doctor Strange level
manipulate oh yes I need things to go in
exact perfect way he did kind of admit
that when he said why don't you tell
them about what I did to you and he's
like well then they you wouldn't be able
to fight for us he is clearly making
chessmen
I'm just wondering retro actually which
ones have we already missed this little
Bobby Fischer is emotionally distancing
himself from everyone so you pointed at
Viktor not artists question acts talking
about brand is alienating everyone so
that afterwards he could say aha see
actually the things that I said had a
deeper meaning if you go back and piece
them all together like a puzzle yeah I
seem like a normal person can't believe
you guys were buying this whole thing
where I didn't make any sense alright
wasn't next artists question my main
question coming out of it is why doesn't
John Justin I wanted the Iron Throne
right away when he tells Danny who he is
and she's upset about is clean what an
episode
I guess my big burning question is do
you think that Danny is gonna dispute
the validity of John's claim to the
throne John and Danny who's gonna kill
who there's three questions in there but
I think they're all kind of about the
same topic yes one is why didn't John
immediately say hey I have no interest
in the Iron Throne right and then she's
asking you know who's gonna kill who and
then the guy in the middle was asking if
Danny's gonna end up challenging his
claim right I mean there is another
witness who they could bring in to prove
his claim Helen Reid was present at the
Tower of joy person alive yeah
theoretically although they did say this
episode anyone who's not here is
basically white now right yeah and he's
further south he's down in moat Cailin
in the yeah and this is a father of
Meera Reed and he was he was with Ned
Stark at the Tower of joy he knows that
Jon Snow isn't actually Ned Stark's
bastard he's the son of Lyanna Stark and
probably if Ned gossips he also knows
he's the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
so I he could be brought in it seems
like he's more important in the books
than in the show they they didn't even
really give him lines and that tower of
joy flashback and yeah so that is one
way that he could prove it
another way they could just simply get
past this is just by marrying each other
and they just bring in a Septon or have
a maester do it or do some you know
shotgun wedding to go to the Westeros
version of Vegas and figure this all out
they can
solve this immediately if they genuinely
love each other who's to say they can't
be Co monarchs it's something that was
predicted by Davos and Varys and Tyrion
why can't why not both why can't they
both be rulers why does hat one have to
be that like I don't see Jon having too
much of an aversion to letting Danny do
who most of the ruling and let her do
most of the speaking and he's just kind
of like Oh sue me but then the question
that our first start as submitter asked
is why didn't he then right away say oh
I'm not like interested in the throne is
it because he actually might be right he
he didn't want to be king of the north
but maybe he wants to be king of the
seven realms so I got a wonder I
actually brought this up a little bit in
our snap reaction we post those every
week right after the episode airs or
just some quick thoughts on it I the
whole series has been building up to
making women seen especially this
episode making women be taken just as
seriously as the men if not more so
right everyone now every major ruler is
basically a woman right now I don't know
what I mean but basically a whole yes
but but everything has been pointing in
that direction if so then I think it
might even go beyond the idea of these
two sides are equal and it kind of could
replace the idea of the firstborn male
heir to the crown prince being worthy I
think they're trying to say well no
maybe this this woman Daenerys who is
the last living child of the previous
king has the better claim and the reason
I'm kind of getting into this thing
about and addressing a person's question
about the claim is because I think that
we got to remember also there's only one
Iron Throne so it's not a no love see
yeah exactly I made that same joke in
this but I think that idea of you can't
share the crown not not not really right
it's it's intrude even on our politics
like we had like you know the top
Democrat and the top Republican shared
the ticket and that's how our country is
run you know maybe who knows how things
would be but that's not that doesn't go
with the ego of people who seek that
kind of it's like the Kang and kodos
Treehouse of Horror episode of The
Simpsons were Bob Dole and Bill Clinton
share the ticket it was like I don't
know
don't leave me I voted for Koto's but
yeah I think you're onto something here
in that the history of Westeros and our
normal history makes it you can't have
like two people even despite how much
better that probably would work if you
had like a partnership at the top of
something making these tough decisions
that's not historically the case there
was the the case of Queen Allison and
King Joe Harris the former Targaryen
aunts ancestors in which they were kind
of Co monarchs even though Jo Harris was
the main monarch and his wife Queen I
was saying who's also his relative they
kind of ruled together and she went in
his stead as a diplomat have like a
secretary of state to to make these
important diplomatic meetings for him
but I think I think this is a time that
those old patriarchal rules need to be
broken and shattered and we saw that
when Jaime knighted Brienne to become a
knight even though women are not
supposed to be Knights I think the show
is signaling that the rules are changing
the wheels are breaking and that we
don't have to have the old rules apply
in this new world that we're gonna build
so if that's true then what's just the
last question we got there who has to
kill who in order to to finalize this
obviously you're kind of implying there
that it would be maybe Danny is trying
to at least be the last one standing
she certainly has made it very clear if
anyone has a terminator like mission
here it's her right she was born for
this she's been told this her whole life
that she that she was destined for this
I guess this era felt like he was fried
but either way she is the one that would
be maybe ruthless enough in order to
claim the throne to maybe be willing to
kill John but if John is potentially
azor Ahai that prophecy talks about
plunging your weapon into you know your
loved one it could be that maybe in her
pursuit of the Iron Throne she goes one
step too far which they have before
shadowed her willingness to do that
before that maybe he has to put an end
to her and it ends up being him at the
end and I think so is either she good
she tries to kill him because she wants
a throne or he has to kill her because
of going mad essentially yeah and we did
see this episode she is kind of in a
downward spiral of authority from
talking with Sansa and Sansa rebuffed
sir and then she finds out the truth
about Jon's true lineage people
even making eye contact with her it
feels like she's losing a lot of her
power this episode yeah and so she might
do what what a cat does went back to
yeah get that right get sassy yes
yeah real sassy yeah I always act
surprised because I'm very loud yes okay
at alley bar told us alley bar told us
wants to know what did Tyrion and brand
talk about besides his journey right
this is talked about earlier it was her
I felt very purposely cut away from yeah
I did also kind of feel where he was
like you know I have time I'll listen to
your story in the very next time we see
Tyrion he's talking to Jamie almost like
he was like I had to get out of that
conversation yeah it didn't imply that
they spent so much time together but
let's assume that they did spend a good
few hours going over everything that
brand has everything that happened
transforming bran into the three-eyed
Raven I think that this could be
actually essential to the events going
for it even though they brushed past it
they have the person with the
established in this episode the most
brilliant mind in Westeros and he has
now the information of the three-eyed
Raven the three-eyed Raven it seems like
he he doesn't he doesn't think in terms
of strategy so much we earlier we talked
about him being the Bobby Fischer of
chess moves but at the same time he kind
of seems passive a bit
Tyrion might be the one that actually
can use this information in a new way in
the last moment yeah this seems like
Tyrians first step to fixing his poor
strategy blunders in previous seasons
and actually going back to what has
always made him clever and stronger than
other people an appreciation of history
you know and see someone he was one of
the few people who believed that White
Walkers actually existed despite it
taking other people five seasons to
learn that truth and he knew the great
kings of the past and that was kind of
his inspiration for being such a good
hand of the king and season two so now
he's like you know what no I'm gonna
stop trusting myself I'm gonna go back
and go to the living history of Westeros
and pick his brain or for three hours so
you mentioned earlier that you think
Tyrion will go down when the crypts
because that's where Tyrion ordered him
we saw him at the end of the episode
despite her telling him to go down there
he's there on the battlements I don't
think he's gonna be in the crypts in the
final episode I think he has an
important role
play based off what brand told him about
maybe some weakness of the night king or
some kind of strategy to decision I
think we're gonna see a repeat of
Tyrians surprises tricks up his sleeve
that he had in the Battle of Blackwater
he is gonna have some kind of new
strategy battle plan that maybe he's
kept from the other people or maybe he
learned last minute some kind of
revision to the battle plan that we're
gonna see unfold in the final run in the
next episode so it certainly a decent
theory that that could happen the one
reason why I'll throw out an alternate
is because I feel like other characters
have been associated with the the
journey I get with the Battle of the
Dead
I considered Sam kind of feels like
maybe the surrogate a little bit for
brand and has and Jon very much
represents that role if anything tyrion
has always represented the politics of
Westeros kind of like Littlefinger did
right it's like almost if Littlefinger
suddenly cared about the night King
would be it'd be off-brand I don't think
that Tyrion necessarily doesn't care but
I think that it's possible that he was
given information that's gonna be
relevant in the episodes after the
Battle of Winterfell
for instance Tyrion might be the you
know the top political mind who now
might know the truth about Jon Snow yeah
so he might know that there's this big
complicated thing on the other side of
if they survive this and then maybe
that's where it'll come into play as him
having this this awareness of who the
rightful king is so it said he could be
handed the king and try to figure out
what his role to play after this battle
is over but what is this we have another
oh my goodness another question
nutmeg 510 asks how old are Aria and
Gendry okay so I wonder what Mike is
asking I genderized nutmeg but I wonder
what nutmeg is asking and so was
everybody else right we have a graphic
here yes apparently a lot of people were
wondering this is one of the top-rated
questions and HBO anticipating this
tweeted out by age 18 and Westeros you
should have all these things and and
alluding to the fact that Arya is like
this bit this tweet basically says Arya
is 18 years old bye-bye but but let's
see her other graphic this is how big
that question was in
moment there's a spike you know for East
Coast time or a little past 9:30 p.m.
9:40 p.m. huge spike Maisie Williams age
yes and I think it's cuz we all got real
scared first am I gonna get ya my door
kicked in by well here's the deal Maisie
Williams who plays Aria is 22 years old
Joe Dempsie plays country is 31 years
old so everyone involved here is a grown
up
they gave if we saw them grow up yes
they are currently growing right and the
showrunners gave Maisie Williams a
hundred percent control over what she
how she would act this and block it what
articles of clothing she would remove
how much you would see Maisie Williams
was in complete control over all that so
we don't have to worry about any weird
stuff happening behind this yes actually
instead of caring about her age I think
it's super fascinating that this is
actually probably the the most
appropriate sex scene that we've
actually never had on this show I you
know it's not done for manipulation it's
not done to try to make a ghost baby
come out of you it's not done for
political reasons like there's nothing
to it other than she wants it and even
with with Gentry she actually is
sensitive I mean it kind of came off as
like a fun little badass moment there
I've like take off your own damn pants
I'm not the red witch whatever yeah but
it actually is like you make the choice
for your part because previously it was
taken from you you know almost was at
least right so she's like look I'm
making my choice you take off your pants
of you if you're down to do it and like
that's the most progressive damn sexy in
the show's ever had yeah it's one of the
most normalized sex scenes it's just
like characters just doing it just for
the feeling like they want to feel what
it's like it's not any kind of weird
political machinations it's not like the
the dragon and the wolf coming together
and is there conspiracy at work here you
know our characters gonna get pregnant I
don't think I have to worry about any of
that here it's just like two young
people who are sexually interested in
each other's impulses on the last night
of the world right that's fine it's okay
and we don't need to worry about any of
it I think this episode had a lot to do
with human connection and what it means
to be alive what living is defined as
right that we had
each about what death means but I think
the episode was about what it means to
be a living human person and because and
that's who were what we're battling for
right that's a human connections we saw
in so many forms we saw sharing a meal
between Sansa and Theon we saw sharing a
drink with all the people in front of
the fire there and and I wasn't sharing
stories and sharing song and then here
you know sharing your bodies right and
and having sex is like this this is one
very important part of human connection
I thought this was like kind of an
amazing moment in this series as a whole
but it did kind of just leave me a
little weird with this this face that
are like this biggest fear but I think
that evokes two have to do with the
death that is coming and not so much huh
so that's sex not interested when aria
always feels alienation you know she
once she hooked up with Gendry B to
follow through on her desire for a
family back in season three and and
she's like you can be my family's like I
wouldn't be her family be my lady and
since then she's been on this journey
invoking the stranger of the seven and
the many-faced God she's kind of death
incarnate and she isn't kind of like how
brand doesn't really feel human anymore
Aria despite trying to feel human in
these final moments is feeling that it's
it's hard for her to just feel the kind
of normal emotions normal people feel
but this is the most back to Aria she's
ever been right previously in Bravos
like she's like oh you're ready to be a
faceless man it's like no turns out I am
are historic this is a desire are you
stork head the whole time
ironically it's also a desire that
Robert Baratheon had right he points out
you have a daughter yeah and it wasn't
these two but these two are much more
healthy relationship than the previous
one yeah for sure yeah okay another
question this one comes from the the
scream of the Raven is always polite
enough to wait till we finish our
previous answer he knows when to come in
han solo 88 asks is Theon in love with
Sansa interesting question uh well let's
look at their history and kind of see
what what that would lead to so they
both escaped Ramsay Bolton together I
remember I think you were with me when
we were watching that episode live that
our friends were like oh my god they
killed themselves yeah
which it was not so they have that you
know that bond forged through pain and
shared you know shared misery which is
in in real life one of the strongest
bonds you can have with someone but
often is is non romantic unless you're
watching a movie and then for no reason
it suddenly becomes romantic yes it
feels like a brother-sister kind of
platonic connection they both yeah they
were both horribly tortured by Ramsay
Bolton and it was kind of defining for
both of them that experience the fact
that they were able to survive it and I
don't think there's any more to it than
that yeah I mean right it's just we were
tortured by a evil tyrant of in a castle
and and we don't talk about it yeah but
if you know it's personally you know who
we're talking about
yeah for sure rankings this is a really
interesting episode for Power Rankings
because it's one that noted anyone who
ever gets voted at the top of the Power
Rankings this week it didn't do it
through threats this was the the most
positive portrayal of these up these
characters so it my opinion it's
probably got to go toward people who at
their core are the best and most
powerful around and you know having to
rely on threats or weapons yeah
emotional victories kind of characters
who are building each other up rather
than like killing each other in battle
so on at third place we have our number
three vote with 9.2% Jaime Lannister
people really which I think yeah it's
it's definitely a power
moment for him because he survived this
trial that he really should not have
gotten a non guilty verdict it's just
really through brand design to spare him
but he didn't fit he made a good
argument for himself by saying that you
know I like the fact that he stood his
ground and stood up for himself I would
do it all again I was protecting my
family aside from maybe the push out the
window is the one thing which he'd like
looked at brand a little bit like good
right you're not gonna like surprise but
I think his his anointing of Brienne and
deciding to come and right fight for her
was in a way a powerful moment for Jaime
as well oh and for this series right
that's kind of touching on what we were
saying earlier this idea of the you know
the previous privilege that has only
been reserved for men like being
knighted but also just being the hero of
this
and potentially ruling in westeros
here's me saying hey I'm passing it you
get it - yeah it also doesn't just come
from Jamie it also comes from tormund
right he's like a Pirate King
yeah I mean he means something different
when he says he'd keep night in her
again a night without the cake yeah but
I do think that that transition moment
is kind of a like you know it's gonna be
sound political I don't mean it to but
essentially like it's like a reach down
and then pull up past the glass ceiling
of Westeros at least yeah for sure
yeah so Jamie had a lot of power to give
but he definitely isn't the most
powerful at all so second place let's
see we have Arya Stark 23.3%
interesting why Arya well definitely a
moment of agency for her to see her act
on her impulses and finally you know bed
Gendry and just to take control of that
scenario also pretty badass moments
where's the way she wins them over is by
you know throwing daggers and the wall
later she does it with with arrows she's
like all right give me another weapon I
wanted yes
but yeah I definitely a powerful moment
for her where she's able to show how
much of a badass she's become over the
course of this series right and and it
shows you know and now I suddenly became
the most hyped for her scenes in this
next battle of course we've only seen
her running but maybe they're actually I
think if you look at her scene with the
Hound it kind of implied to me that
they're gonna have a little bit of a
Cyclops and Wolverine a pair up of like
in the battlefield like you know he'll
throw her into she just immediately
different no but uh she has her weapon
finally I think they kind of established
we're gonna have a player in the field
who is you know level 10 in skill and
now I'm like super hyped for that so
aside from what you know she was able to
do for a character they also set her up
to be the most badass person to watch on
the field and kind of a powerful moment
for her to acknowledge to the hound and
beric Dondarrion that she no longer has
them on their kill list and she's like
I'm not gonna spend my last night in the
world with you too old which was an
unscripted line the actress was actually
saying that to those actors yes it was
very mean actually yeah
uh-uh who's in first first place
obviously sir Brienne of Tarth 37.2%
undisputed smiled that smile that like
it's huge and kind of a little like a
happy mr. burns look to it but oh man
did I I mean I teared up yeah this is
exactly what she's always wanted to
become a knight from the very beginning
of her arc in the series she wanted to
be able to she's already been more of a
knight in her actions her behavior her
outlook than every other character on
the show she embodies all the qualities
that a knight is supposed to embody
whereas all the other characters who
actually have knighthood have been in
some ways false knights and their
behavior had betrayed and broken their
vows in other various ways and then
redeemed themselves but through and
through Brienne has been the true knight
it's nice to see her finally come into
the title of this thing that she's
earned over and over again yeah it goes
with the the point I was making earlier
of this episode whoever had the most
power was gonna be probably someone who
like internally kind of kind of had it
it does make me worry about her a bit
moving forward how much more growth can
she have as a character and it's worth
pointing out the titleist episode a
knight of the seven kingdoms is bait is
what was used in context of her when
when Jaime knighted her and then Tyrion
gave her the toast so she is the knight
of the Seven Kingdoms yeah this episode
is remember it's about being human and
what it means to be alive this is the
character that expresses that you know
in the most potential fulfilled way and
again this is something real quick to
just point out here becoming a knight
and being knighted is insanely huge
right it's not like her getting the
promotion she wanted that has to go into
history books like they have to now
write and record who knighted her now
she is knighted she's gonna be written
as the first confirm she is the first
female Knight of the Seven Kingdoms like
that's gonna go down in the in the
Citadel history that's amazing
yeah for sure well now let's let's end
every Westeros weekly as we always do by
watching the teaser for next week's
episode give you a quick thoughts on it
cool let's do it
mr. right thing we can do now flip the
trace in the face
the night king is coming
the dead are already here whoo-hoo and
not a single shot of the night King not
a single shot we saw a dragon but it did
look like this Ariane it looked like
drogon you couldn't really see who's
riding the back him probably it was
Danny
but yeah so still no night king and also
an interesting line from Daenerys to
John the dead are already here is that a
line implied the fact that the dead are
already here they're down in our crypts
they're already amongst us absolutely
and we see we saw in the previews of the
Battle of the bastard we saw a lot of
sword fighting we didn't see that here
right we see a little bit of flaming
arrow a little bit of fires or whatnot
but we didn't even see the whites really
like not really oh yeah so we just saw
people inside of the castle on the run
or feeling like they're being attacked
in there it also reminds me of the siege
that was done on it was it on Castle
Rock Oh with the UH that it came from
the inside and yeah I didn't expect it
coming I mean it'd be very strategic of
them and they don't tend to work that
way but it does feel like we're up for
some sort of huge misdirect yes next
week that might involve vacating the
castle the way the the Lannisters did at
Casterly Rock that might have the only
way to avoid these zombies resurrect
Evander crypts is just evacuate right
which is kind of a moment at the end of
Buffy but it just a lot of your
references but just that idea of the
places and isn't what actually matters
right it's the people yeah so I'd be
interested weakly we got to get some
rest before next huge Battle of
Winterfell but we have also plenty of
content coming all week yeah we'll be
both be working on thanks so much for
watching and listening to this do not
forget to subscribe both to the new rock
stars YouTube channel and to this
Westeros weekly podcast feed everything
that Eric's got coming up will also come
out on that feed and followed that new
MCU podcast inside marble for all of our
adventures and game content also
reminder that we're having an endgame
screening at the El Capitan it's gonna
be like epic I'm so excited yeah there's
very few tickets left actually uh and
they're also having like a VIP
afterparty meet-and-greet will have some
special
yes it's gonna be super exciting we'll
have a link to that in the show notes
and description below if you want to
join us to watch Avengers endgame with
us at the basically official Disney
theater that's gonna be amazing follow
us on twitter at new rock stars tweet
your Game of Thrones questions with the
hashtag Westeros weekly and follow me at
beam on Twitter and a Phillip Molina on
Instagram and you can follow me on
twitter instagram @ EA vas thanks
everyone
bye-bye have a good one
[Music]